c'est revenu longuement sur ce braquage
on apprenait notamment quelque chose
vous avez regardé il ya eu il ya eu un
truc qu'on a appris c'est qu'il avait un
contact avec un membre de l'entourage de
la star américaine créée y avait donc
une taupe chez kim kardashian regarde à
omar aït kheddache 60 ans alias la pince
pauline delassus journaliste à paris
match a recueilli ses confidences en
détention selon elle il serait le
cerveau de l'opération après avoir eu un
tuyau en or d'un certain gary chauffeur
du clan kardashian à paris aux mains va
souvent dans un bistrot de la rue de
bretagne où ils n'ont qui connaît bien
le patron qui lui dit qu'il est copain
avec un chauffeur la famille kardashian
comprennent qu'il ya de l'argent à se
faire
alors c'est vrai qu'il y avait donc sur
66 minutes c'est vrai que ça tout le
monde en a parlé de ce braquage la
planète entière
l'émission aussi fait une reconstitution
du braquage en interrogeant younis et
regardez il va nous dire s'il est
d'accord avec cette version des faits ou
pas dans un instant bien arriveront
rentrant tv lula mais dans la cour à
l'intérieur dont on s'habille et kawaï
casquette marqué police et y en a un qui
ce qui va vers la porte et hambourg il
est chic rivalis bref il s'exécute il
veut dire quoi
il va pas aller lui tend la main j'ai
attrapé le bras comme ça j'ai fait du
mal à y est d'ailleurs il le sait que
j'ai 10 ans de liquide aux courtiers
sont rentrés elle avait une chemise de
nuit transparente pied laissé entrevoir
ses parents où les lions 10 ring ring
ring la liant à la bague la bague
puissant vu que tout était là tout était
ce qui est posé devant roldan qu'ils ont
eu qu'à servir
alors il va venir nous rejoindre et vous
allez voir que le concierge n'est pas
d'accord avec la version 2 c'est un
événement donc nous recevons l'auteur
d'un des vols les plus retentissants de
ces dernières années dans la nuit du 3
octobre 2016 kim kardashian est à paris
les choses vont mal tourner pour l
séquestré et ligoté
elle a été volée dans sa chambre d'hôtel
ils ont volé pour 9 millions d'euros
dans cette histoire un retentissement
mondial d'autant plus que ce cambriolage
est l'oeuvre de papy braqueur des
truands sexagénaire qui sont repartis de
l'onel de tel avec 9 millions chf mon
vélo et oui donc ce soir nous ni sabah
sera avec nous dans la dans une minute
juste après ce petit récapitulatif et
surtout il ya plein de gens qui se pose
la question comment se fait-il qu'il
soit là et bien nous expliquer pourquoi
il est là et comment se fait-il qu'ils
soient en liberté regarde kardashian
agressé cette nuit à paris
tomas vokoun mais c'est le plus gros
braquage de ces vingt dernières années
celui de la star américaine kim
kardashian
dans la nuit du 2 au 3 octobre 2016
alors qu'elles seront dans son hôtel
particulier du 8e arrondissement de
paris cinq hommes déguisés en policiers
séquestre la star dans sa chambre
opération réussie
le commando repartait notamment avec ce
diamant à 4 millions de dollars montant
total du butin neuf millions d'euros
il commet un tel braquage at-il pu être
commis en plein paris qu'ils sont les
auteurs ce soir younis abbas l'un des
cinq ravisseurs de kim kardashian était
avec nous il a décidé de tout nous dire
sur cette fameuse nuit du braquage
younis abbas est avec nous l'un des
cambrioleurs du vol le plus
spectaculaire de ces dernières années
connaît tous la version officielle de la
fère et unissent en a livré une autre
dans son livre il va nous en livrer une
autre les motivations la préparation de
cambriolages la kabbale il va tous nous
racontez vous avez 67e younis échelle
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui 67 n'ont pas aujourd'hui on
en sort enfin maintenant j'ai 66 être le
moment de les affaires serre la vis et
63 63 exactement
alors vous savez qu'il ya plein de gens
et on le dit aux téléspectateurs et je
vous en parlais déjà avec electronic
arts et vous qu'en dit pourquoi vous
recevez younis guillaume genton il ya
plein de gens qui ont commis des délits
bien plus graves qui sont à l'antenne
qui sont reçus dans des émissions je me
souviens de redouane fait qu'ils aient
fait le tour des plateaux télé peu
moment pour raconter son histoire
pardon et tout l'été les émissions de
faits divers comme faites entrer
l'accusé qui donne parfois la parole à
des coupables de faits bien plus graves
le fond donc j'ai pas pourquoi nous on
pourrait pas interroger ce monsieur qui
a sans doute une histoire à raconter moi
j'ai eu un sourire c'est très
intéressant
j'ai vu là il est en liberté provisoire
il a fait 22 mois de prison avant il
sera jugé bientôt ils risquent de très
longues années de prison mais là pour
moi ya pas de scandale il a écrit un
livre qui donne vraiment sa version et
tente vous tentez beaucoup de vous
disculper ça normal de devaux est généré
de responsabilité mais il n'y a pas de
scandale à le recevoir
ça s'appelle la liberté d'expression
mais kim kardashian si elle avait voulu
aurait pu tenter un référé pour
interdire le livre parce qu'elle n'a pas
fait alors unissent donc on va parler de
la préparation c'est donc entre
guillemets le coup du siècle que vous
aviez préparé à 5 chacun 20 rôle précis
et la cible était identifié la star
internationale kim kardashian c'est lui
qui était kim kardashian pas du tout pas
du tout quoi
je ne connaissais pas du tout ah ouais
donc je ne savais rien et je savais la
famille kardashian c'est les séries que
j'ai jamais regardé d'accord donc vous
saviez pas du tout qui s'était pas du
tout pourquoi est ce que vous l'avez
choisi l appât elle s'est sentie avant
qu'on a choisi c'est son diamant
vous avez vous avez eu une info bah il
était sur internet actions françaises
pour moi qui le num
comment on est venu vous voir pour vous
parler de cette affaire en cdd
connaissances et les connaissances qui
vous ont dit quoi qu'en dise et
intéresser une opération kavo diamant
d'un carat
ouais on constate tout de suite que ça
vaut 400 ça dépend de la couleur 4 5 6
millions d'euros
donc là on s'y intéresse parce que des
affaires où vous prenez 4 millions n'a
pas
alors comment vous avez su qu'elle
serait seul ce soir là vous avez
refermant qu'être c'est compliqué oui
mais c'est important comment lassus sa
vieille taupe
vous avez des nations enfin dans une
mine de renseignements ont heureusement
où ça à l'hôtel non à l'automne pas
tellement ont certainement de son
entourage mais c'est pour moi qui ai
géré ce avant que je pourrais le jeu
d'accord on va voir vos québécois dans
les détails a eu des fuites via quadri
livre alors alors si si et si vous
saviez ce que vous cherchiez vous avez
besoin est toujours une très grande
valeur comme il l'a dit ces bijoux cette
fortune c'est pas compliqué de savoir
qu'elle les avait puisque vous le savez
et les exposer tout le temps donc si
vous la connaissiez pas vos amis voilà
le le saviez donc à la base vous y allez
vraiment pour ses bijoux là pour cette
bague surtout à montréal pour la bague
exactement alors le soir vous décidé
d'agir elle est donc seul dans cet hôtel
parisien de luxe
il y à un veilleur de nuit mais son
garde du corps est avec sa soeur en
boîte de nuit
oui bah c'est normal le gars du gol la
raccompagner chez elle il a pu vous
adresser il s'en va s'est enfermée chez
elle
surtout à l'hôtel ils disent et secure
bah oui normalement et le départ
d'audrey qu'il rase ses services il
intéressé ça n'a pas été normale
alors vous le saviez tout ça on pas
qu'elle avait une si faible aux
protections vous savez qu'il n'était
plus là on attendait ce moment
bien sûr on sait qu'on a été on l'a fait
à deux heures du matin donc le
cambriolage vous avez donc dans cet
hôtel à bille en faux policiers alors
non on rentre pas en fonte
positionneront rentant betis d'accord
tranquillement donc le soir comme ça
vous fait du vtt tranquille vous avec
gilet réfléchissant moi j'avais un an je
les avais un réfléchissantes jours donc
l'hôtel y étaient fermés ou bien
vous avez d'abord sur la rue était
ouverte pour ça on s'en était assurée
aussi elle était ouverte
d'accord vous rentrez vous faites quoi
non sous le porche
il ya deux caméras en eau ouais on avait
apporté de quoi les deux camouflets mais
on s'est aperçu que c'était trop tôt on
pouvait pas le faire d'accor le renier
réfléchissant bien on s'est aperçu
qu'elle servait à rien pourquoi passer
des personnalités qui viennent doivent
pas se faire photographier elles veulent
pas faire venir les grands hôtels comme
ça les caméras ne marche pas pas dans
ces endroits là dit c'est pas un grand
total s'est encore montrée très modeste
mais alors bernard montiel ça dans le
nom c'est une résidence privée en fait
alors c'est pas vraiment un hôtel c'est
un endroit très spécifique dans paris où
effectivement les plus grandes stars
loue cet endroit il ya un gardien à
l'entrée il ya un service un room
service si on veut etc
mais c'est pas un hôtel comme on peut
l'imaginer et donc est donc là il n'y a
pas de caméra en fait non parce que
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de relations
coupables dirais-je
il ya de nombreux hommes d'affaires qui
viennent passer l'après-midi et partir
après vous le saviez ça vous savez que
caméra web et s'il savait tout ah oui
vous le saviez évidemment que vous le
saviez bah oui vous le savez on le sait
ça me sert dit moi je ne savais pas et
si c'est interdit pouvais me ramener qui
vous voulez mais personne ne soit parce
que c'est pas filmés alors donc là vous
arrivez en vététistes alors on s'habille
en étroit d'abord d'accord on s'habille
avec des cacahuètes policiers une
casquette de policier mais les produits
de cinéma qu'on achète facile d'acheter
ça ou vous avez trouvé ça sur internet
sur la résolution sont d'accord donc
vous voilà c'est d'accord on a mis ça on
a nui en ou moi je me suis pas gouré de
mon collègue des cagoules et le
troisième est resté
j'ai découvert il a frappé à la porte et
la conscience police police ouvrez
ouvrez tu as dit oui j'aime bien je
pense est d'accord au concierge il a
ouvert la porte a dit vous venez pour
l'adresse vous voulez qu'on a droit oui
c'est un endroit connu pour ça aussi
oui quand les dealers de paris savent ce
qui se passe en vendant droite ou par
lots cette ut prison hausse avec chez
tous les ans le sam est donc donc le
second siège si vous venez pour la
drogue et là vous lui dites quoi donc
bah ils se plient latorre de la police à
bron plus tard on saura qu'il était sans
papiers c'est un autre sujet oui
monsieur mais c'est un autre sujet et
donc moi et que donc il s'est hissé
plier aurait il s'est laissé faire il a
pas discuté pendant qu'au rond qui
discutaient nous on l'a entouré bon j'ai
attrapé le bras je les couche et j'ai
fait un petit balayette j'ai envoyé par
terre bon là je me suis retourné sur lui
j'ai attaché à voter oui c'est bon c'est
lui qui l'a plaqué au sol et qui lui a
mis je crois le bracelet a rigolé oui
mais je rigole pas du tout simplement
c'est ça qui la trahissent et l'adn qui
avait sur ses bras ses moyens non en
fait c'est pas le mieux votre adn qui
avait été dans un hold up en belgique et
leur médaille vous à retrouver comme ça
aulas est ce que vous dites dans le
livre en tout cas alors alors le mb oui
alors y'en a qui est pas d'accord
le concierge aussi séquestré donc que
l'émission a retrouvé dans 66 minutes et
qui dit que votre équipe a bel et bien
exhibé une arme devant kim kardashian
dernier les banques d'incompréhension
[Musique]
réécrit commencé à crier ma femme allait
braquer les volets de ces finales donc
suffi de la calmer
on ne parle jamais des zombies alors
vous pointer une arme avec vos complices
de noël c'était vraiment obligé de la
ligue n'ont justement c'est moi je suis
toujours perplexe sur larmes parce que
moi nous en donne on n'avait pas quand
ils ont été ensemble n'avaient pas parce
qu'ils en ont sorti une aot l'âge ils
ignorent moi je suis pas monté j'ai pas
le contact de madame kardashian donc le
cambriolage quand il commet donc vos
pays rentrer vos complices contre il ya
eu crime car d'action dans la chambre le
sénat vous espina lisent ce que j'en
sais bien sûr que moi je suis pour
monter et oui mais voulait j'ai eu
désinformation ya bien sûr vous n'êtes
pas monter ou non je suis pas devant
s'appelle votre yves g séquestré à vous
n'êtes pas montré mais vous avez ce que
ça j'ai participé je suis confuse dans
la sphère après déjà joué connaissent
histoire ali le nist qu'est-ce qui donc
quand on a mobilisé le concierge mes
deux collègues amal ont pris sont
contraignants demandé la clé la chambre
il nous a tout donné
la sq est normal il a tout donné il a
accompagné mes collègues et moi je suis
resté en bas à la place à la réception
pour vale pas trop savoir les gens si
quelqu'un venait d'accord vous avez joué
donc le gros lot aussi un concierge
il y avait deux autres personnes qui
sont rock qui sont arrivées pour nous
soutenir nous aider en cas ou si on a
été débordé d'accord n'hésitez pas bien
en policier comme l'a dit le reportage
d'accord ils sont trompés alors donc là
vos complices ils ont la clé y rentre
dans la chambre de kim kardashian et
rentrer dans l'argent du beurre la jambe
donc ce que le compte rendu qu'on va
faire après sûr c'est que lui ont pris
son téléphone est un téléphone est un
espèce de voile sur elle elle était
assise en tailleur a le téléphone a été
tout seul elle était toute seule
d'accord ils ont vu personne d'autre
jusque dans la presse coach au moment où
on a su qu'ils avaient la secrétaire
nous renverser portée des personnes
dégustent une carnation
donc là on dit là bas elle était posée
sur le bord dudit sur le cheveu ou bref
il y aura donné la bague n'a pas résisté
à la donne et ses bijoux son coffre à
bijoux
d'accord ils ont près et l'ont
activement attaché les mains avec du
scotch et ils ont jeté sur le sur le lit
ils ont laissé sur le lit il sont partis
c'est la dernière vague pour 9 millions
d'euros
oui non mais je dis bien la bike plus
encore bien sûr donc 9 millions d'euros
de butin
mais tu libye je n'étais pas n'étaient
pas les siens d'accord oui mais quand
même donc pendant ce temps là vraiment
ravi la responsable dans des combats
vous fait le guet donc c'est ça on fait
le dieu ça a duré s'était très
rapidement
je crois qu'on a réussi moins 10 minutes
entre 7 et 8 millions doit de rester
alors on à la réaction de kim kardashian
après bien sûr vous allez nous en parler
car kim kardashian qui a été
profondément marqué par cette affaire
c'est pas simplement pour un vol de
bijoux c'est l'agression était très
violente psychologiquement port elle s
est même préparer au pire
regardez vous voyez c'est comme ça ça
vous fait quelque chose ou pas ça me
gêne pas ça vous gêne
bien sûr bah c'est marrant moi je vous
ai vu vous marrez plutôt bons le sujet
oui j'ai vu à n'attend que ça vous fait
rire ça ne peut pas rien bah si je me
suis dit c'est vous qui me fait rire
c'est vrai que du talent vous me
chercher je vous vois arriver vous
menacez en plus non je
je vais me chercher je vous vois pas ce
que je vous trouve pas légitimes suis
mais je m'en fiche
pourquoi je ne pourrais pas des victimes
je m'en fiche sur quoi parce qu'il est
en train de faire l'apologie d'un crime
qu'il a commis
je fais aucunement pour lequel il est
jugé non mais ça je dis tout de suite je
suis bien sûr le lendemain il ay
regrette il n'a rien fait mais il à
titus son livre j'ai séquestrés je
trouve absurde qu'on reçoit ce monsieur
partout dans les médias que tu le
reçoivent tu as raison parce que les
autres ont fait donc à vous en donner
c'est bien aussi qu'on le commandant
nous on a envie de savoir c'est un an
les attend des excuses mais c'était bien
placé pour en parler
je trouve ça je trouve ça limite que
quelqu'un qui est en cours de jugement
viennent en plus fanfaronner sur tous
les plateaux de télé je vois votre
attitude vous regardez kardashian qui
pleure ça vous fait marrer je vous
trouve vraiment ignoble voile alors
trouvé monde que vous avez ou qu'est ce
que vous répondez aux gens qui disent
qu'il faut pas vous invite etc
c'est leur droit moi j'avais tout de
suite regretté ce que vous avez fait moi
je leur ai été celui c'est pour ça que
je voulais le dire vous êtes un culte
efforts sur quelques chiffres sur lequel
pardon excusez moi voulons bande
organisée séquestration et association
de malfaiteurs en récidive complicité
d'accord alors que vous allez finalement
furent avec le bulletin le butin à vélo
et ça vous êtes tous à vélo
oui c'est vous qui transportait des
bijoux une partie à part la bague qui
est dans un sac qui ne ferme pas c'est
sa seule inverse mais bon voilà prêt et
donc la caisse qui deviennent les bijoux
ce qui les bijoux ils ont toujours pas
été reconnue banon mais elles seront
parcourus mais ils ont été vendus tout
de suite à une chose qu'on met à l'abri
c'est le buste en a toujours
donc vous avez tir trouvait pas le butin
alors et le butin il a apparemment la
police d'être à n'était pas loin l'a
suivi elle a perdu en cours de route
elle a perdu bêta parce qu'en partant
vous croisez une voiture de police et à
sang voilà vous dit que c'est fini c'est
ça je pense que c'est cuit pour ma part
pour moi et ça qu'un un moment vous
tombez et vous fait on
des bijoux dans le caniveau c'est un
coin m non mais pareil vous pensez que
certains bijoux sont restés par terre
c'est incroyable non c'est quand on
connaît l'histoire que c'est ce qui
s'est passé c'est pas incroyable
simplement comme j'avais vu la voiture
de police avec le sac fermé pas et que
je tenais ans je tenais avec le guidon
d'accord ça m'a déconcentré
j'ai survécu jeudi à venir à pau nice
elle arrive à la rivale arrive puis
finalement elle n'est pas venue et le
temps que j'en prenne les esprits le sac
s'est pris dans la roue avant j'ai fait
rouler bouler mais j'ai rebondi chez
retomber sur mes deux jambes et gérard
et il avait un pneu crevé je crois
j'aimerais en plus des pratiques donc il
est tombé et ça s'est déversé sur la
route alors vous avez donc le téléphone
de kim kardashian aussi dans la poche
alors ça je découvre sur la route je
sais pas ah ouais vous aviez de
téléphone de kim kardashian est avec
vous le lendemain vous êtes sur toutes
les télés du monde entier
qu'est-ce que vous êtes dit à ce moment
là vous avez été surmontée jude en fait
une grosse connerie fallait pas y
toucher
ça vous allez y on a fait une grosse
connerie mais non solo vous pour quand
ça a pris une telle ampleur comme ça
vous êtes dit quoi vous êtes diront faut
qu'on finisse aurait dû y penser avant
non que je la connaissais pas j'ai pas
pensé on m'avait dit que c'était
quelqu'un telle attente d'un rappeur
quelqu'un de célèbre un rapport célèbre
je vais pas chercher à savoir qui
c'était j'ai pas voulu donc j'ai été
surpris gilles verdez on n'a pas la
vérité judiciaire mais la manière dont
vous présentez notamment ce qui s'est
passé dans l'appartement au tour de kim
kardashian est très édulcoré par rapport
à certains autres certaines versions du
dossier vous le savez très bien certains
disques kim kardashian aurait été
victime de quelques attouchements il ya
eu ça au début qu'à circuler
et deuxième chose qu'elle aurait été
ligotée dans la salle de bains notamment
savent où le démonter mais ça alourdit
le dossier vous le savez bien monsieur
il ya des versions autre que la bulle
c'est pour ça que j'ai fait ma version
c'est parce que j'en ai eu marre
d'entendre les médias racontent excusez
moi quelques conneries mais quelques
conneries que j'ai vécu des déinocoques
j'ai vécu les événements je sais que
c'est pas ce qui se passe mais vous
n'étiez pas là où monsieur pour autant
non je suis d'accord mais sur l'autre
partie dont veut se parlant à jamais
attaché attaché comment par exemple
les attouchements je sais qu'ils ont
jamais eu lieu si je connais des
personnes avec qui j'étais
j'ai des personnes qui ont une certaine
réputation jamais aura fait ligoter dans
la baignoire mois la version que j'ai
c'est sur le lit nous importe je
parierais pas non plus je la perds
nicolas heureux moi j'ai une question
qui est plus personnel vous avez quel
âge monsieur l'abbé sur scène trois ans
au moment des faits qu'elle peut être
votre motivation vous êtes père de
famille dont vous n'êtes pas père de
famille et je suis même grand père le
grand père mais d'où il peut être votre
motivation à 63 ans avec la vie que vous
avez eue de faire ce genre j'ai fait et
tout à ça je pensais qu'il avait arrêté
quatre miss répondu jean franchement
même moi je ne les explique pas bon
peut-être histoire de faire un billet en
passant en se disant c'est un billet
tranquille si j'avais tout juste c'est
le dernier coup c'est le dernier coup de
trop ces derniers coups de brosse à
dents les coûts de trouer vis-à-vis de
votre famille comment ça se passe voilà
en quoi c'est une catastrophe
c'est pas fini alors mes enfants mon vol
ma femme a toujours regretté younis
vraiment bien sûr mais vous êtes laisser
embrigader là dedans
saviez vous c'est le coût toujours les
conneries tu étais capable
c'est plus qu'un pas et puis à la
hauteur des renards est capable de faire
confiance aujourd'hui
peur de quoi non l'adulte est de retour
ce qui va mal oui mais je touche verte
au décès sur entre 5 et 12 ans ont dit
éventuellement en haut je pense mines et
vous avez peur de ça j'ai pas vraiment
peur de la prison parce que ça me fait
plus peur j'en ai fait d'avoir des amis
il avait un temps déjà la plume avoir
votre famille la prison c'est toujours
compliqué c'est une gestion et les
rapports de force
c'est une liberté qui a disparu mais pas
seulement disparaît de même le simple
fait d'aller et venir d'aller à la
douche et l'autorisation
enfin bref c'est compliqué mais j'ai pas
vraiment tort parce que j'ai accepté
j'en accepte l'auguré
si elle doit arriver ça va arriver là
j'ai juste vous dites que vous ne
connaissiez pas avec l'incarnation à
l'époque des faits aujourd'hui vous la
connaissez on a l'impression que vous
avez pas beaucoup de respect pour elle
quand on lit votre livre vous l'appelez
la star virtuelle numéro 1 l'icône des
médias bêta miroir d'une époque pleine
de vide est ce que ça vous énerve cette
génération de stars avec des mii
voire des milliards sur le compte parce
qu'ils sont milliardaires avec sans
forcément avoir de talent je vais pas me
défausser
mais comme vous savez j'ai un coauteur
j'ai pas la qualification pour un feu
dans la la c'est en hauteur je peux mais
je veux pas me presser j'assume a bien
sûr mais c'est bien c'est bien de le
dire ça oui c'est est-ce que alors pour
rester un peu plus moins agressif parce
que non je suis fan ou non le jour
non mais vous m'en voyez vous pas
franchement ça manque quand même pas une
contre l'autre est ce que vous vous
imaginez que le fait de faire votre
livre ça peut vraiment être très très
mauvais un oui contre vous oui parce que
vous êtes toujours pas jugés oui
aujourd'hui on sait qui vous a libéré
bon moi je suis d'accord pourquoi libéré
au bout de 22 mois vous avez fait 22
mois de préventif c'est ça oui que vous
soyez libérés c'est normal et raisons de
santé oui mais non mais même ces on
prévoit toujours la liberté la liberté
plutôt que l'incarcération céder ses
droits mais vous êtes au courant que ça
risque franchement de vous aggravez se
livre alors je me dis que la juge je
siège va faire quoi enfin les juges de
siège où vous voir parader dans l'est
dans les journaux dans l'est dans les
magazines sur les télés sur les radios
et 11e et en plus le mariage avec nous
je leur ai tenu le même discours déjà
avant qu'il me relâche je leur ai dit
c'est pas normal que tout le dossier
sans retrouver sur la place publique ce
qu'on appelle le secret d'instruction ça
existe plus depuis longtemps
oui mais il ya ce qu'on appelle se
connaissent il faut qu'on vous en passer
en correctionnelle c'est pas grave mais
quand vous passez en procédure
criminelle
vous avez à faire un jury populaire tu
n'est censé décider de la peine de la
sanction que de ce qu'il a entendu
à l'audience mais pas si l'influencé
avant par la rue octobre je suis
d'accord mais le jury populaire avait
même si il a envie de livres lire votre
livre puisque voilà il va aussi avoir du
coup l'aspect le plus sombre de cette
histoire de vous porter dans les deux
versions
moi j'ai une dernière question à vous
poser et 21h16 est-ce que vous avez un
message à dire à kim kardashian elle
peut très bien la voir oui presse que
vous avez un message
alors ça sera le même que j'ai déjà
donné dans plusieurs
interview à savoir que je lui demande de
me pardonner je m'excuse si elle peut
pardonner parce qu'elle était
traumatisée
bien sûr elle ressentit qu'elle a vécu
c'est parce que j'avais j'ai vu la
personne à touchable quelles étaient ses
cirques alors une carnation n'importe
quelle personne c'est extrêmement
traumatisant bien sûr mais bien sûr bien
sûr qu est ce que vous avez lu dire
encore une fois je vous demande pas de
me pardonner si elle accepte 6e si elle
ne veut pas vivre avec comme j'ai
toujours vécu avec j'ai personnellement
je bonne réussite qu'elle continue sa
carrière tant mieux pour elle j'ai rien
contre elle servait elle me charge et
apple chargée ça venait d'échapper fait
ce qu'elle veut voilà libre à elles
vibrent lg aucun ressenti j'ai aucune
mauvaise impression sur elle j'avais
fait une connerie
oui je fais pas une connerie une grosse
connerie
j'aurais jamais dû rencontrer dans cette
affaire dont je l'ait fait j'assume
géant vous voir enfin ce oui je suis un
grand cerf oui j'ai un passé de
gangsters mais là ce coup là c'est le
coup de trop je n'aurais pas dû le faire
le coup de trop celle libre nous que de
trop celle de livres l'obs lviv et l'air
il a raison mais bon c'est le livre le
coup de com vous regardez le lie avec
250 pages et 70 pas charger et moi j'en
veux j'en veux aux éditeurs je passais
archipel où je sais pas quoi alors je
leur en veux beaucoup de vous de vous
plier parce que c'est pas un bon exemple
pour notre jeunesse c'est pas un objet
un bon exemple pour la police qui vous a
couru après qui vous a arrêté
aujourd'hui la police à vous arrête à
vous voit sur les plateaux télé
fanfaronner sherbrooke et chez ruquier
chez chez m6 et xavier je sais pas quoi
c'est qui celle ci si la firme ça on
s'en fout moi je dis qu'ils ont par
exemple mais non on fanfaronne pas
l'exemple il est mauvais tout à l'heure
tu as parlé d'un bridge où j'apparais
d'un bris quand il ya une policière qui
a laissé sa vie mais sur les brigands
cela dit aurélie fouquet mais il ne faut
pas oublier que cet exemple on peut
critiquer les anges de la télé réalité
mais faire des livres grâce à là c'est
pire que les anges de la télé ça
younis moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est
vraiment j'espère que vous regrettez ce
que vous avez fait j'espère que voulait
pas donner ça comme exemple à vos
enfants vous obtiendrez des enfants ils
n'ont jamais connu de la justice
jamais et voilà et c'est en 40 ans
espère que vous pourrit est le message
que vous devez faire passer c'est que
c'est pas un bon exemple que vous
regrettez que vous avez fait une énorme
connerie et qu'aujourd'hui vous aurez la
référer vivre une vie normale
plutôt que de faire cette connerie et
d'écrire oui ce sont eux qui le livre
j'en attends rien que la justice va
s'emparer des droits mais servent à tout
prendre
en tout cas merci d'avoir été avec nous
avoir invités ou ne pas accepter
voilà en tout cas j'ai séquestré kim
kardashian et kim kardashian qui a été
extrêmement traumatisés comme tous les
gens voilà qui me connaissent ce genre
d'événements tragiques est vraiment
younis vous avez fait une énorme
connerie
en tout cas on va suivre votre procès